du sport à présent avec du cyclisme ce
week end non pas une mais deux courses à
étapes ont lieu dans la région
le tour d'eure-et-loir et le tour du
loiret un embouteillage provoqué par les
bouleversements du calendrier engendrée
par la crise sanitaire nous votre vont à
la rude sur le tour du loiret bonjour
alain vous vous trouvez actuellement à
châtillon coligny
nous sommes dans l'est du loiret donc
pas très loin de la forêt d'orléans dans
ce bourg dans cette commune de châtillon
coligny nous par la deuxième étape de ce
tour du loiret 2021 alors comme la
quasi-totalité des compétitions
sportives
ce tour avait été annulée en 2020 et les
organisateurs ont tout bonnement repris
le parcours prévu l'an dernier pour
l'actuel 42e édition de cette épreuve
sur trois jours qui a débuté hier et
donc calendrier identique en
eure-et-loir en ce moment même les
équipes du 52e tour doré loire s'élance
depuis courville sur earth et près de
dreux
là encore il s'agit du tracé qui n'avait
pu être parcourus en 2020
contrairement au tour du loiret qui
présente essentiellement des coureurs
amateurs français de nationale une
le tour d'eure-et-loir lui est très
européen avec des équipes belges
britanniques slovaques ou même italienne
avoue maintenant donc bien sûr de faire
votre choix mais sachez que les départs
et les arrivées se font à huis clos
bien qu'il y ait quand même quelques
dizaines de spectateurs autour de nous
en ce moment même et cet après midi les
coureurs donc amateurs du tour du loiret
franchiront la ligne vers 16h20 à
châtillon sur loire
et c'est le même horaire pour l'arrivée
à dreux des coureurs du tour
d'eure-et-loir
merci beaucoup a lancé merci également à
isabelle racine qui vous accompagnent